concentrer
mais la parole
monsieur le Président du Sénat madame la
ministre monsieur le ministre mes chers
collègues pour comprendre l'Afrique
encore faut-il la connaître je m'y suis
rendu 57 fois depuis 2015 et elle
m'étonne à chaque fois je vous livre
trois anecdotes tout d'abord celle de
cette entrepreneur français qui a subi
un vol dans sa société il se rend à la
police on le renvoie vers la dame aux
balais qui lui communique un nom après
avoir utilisé deux balais croisées après
vérification sur sa vidéo surveillance
il découvre qu'elle a raison que dire de
se compatriote qui croit son
portefeuille volé à son domicile affolé
une personne à son service par
précipitamment chez le marabout qui lui
réveille que le portefeuille était la
vue de tous et que personne ne le voit
elle rentre avec le message du marabout
le portefeuille est retrouvé une heure
plus tard oublier près de la piscine
ou encore ce consul général qui fait
venir chaque année un coupeur de pluie
pour s'assurer de célébrer le 14 juillet
au sec après deux heures de réception le
coupeur de pluie lui demande s'il peut
partir dès son départ la pluie se remet
à tomber sur le consulat les esprits
cartésiens seront dubitatifs
notre consult général ne se fait pas
rembourser la prestation par le Quai
d'Orsay
Olivier leloure conseiller des Français
de l'étranger établis depuis 20 ans en
Afrique m'a confié qu'il se refuse à
expliquer l'Afrique à quelqu'un qu'il
n'y a pas vécu déjà au moins 5 ans on
aborde souvent à tort la stratégie
française en Afrique par un seul prisme
c'est une erreur car il n'y a pas une
Afrique mais des Afrique chacune a des
problématiques bien distinctes même si
certaines se recoupent Emmanuel Macron a
visité 25 pays africains depuis sa
première élection en mai 2017 ce qui
fait de lui le dirigeant ayant le plus
d'engagement diplomatique avec les
nations africaines pourtant sur le
continent africain et plus
particulièrement en Afrique de l'Ouest
et au Sahel on nous répète que le
sentiment anti français ne cesse de
croître
et si c'était une fake news entretenue
illustrant la guerre hybride livrée à la
France pour nous affaiblir nous nous
fions trop au réseau sociaux animé par
les activistes aujourd'hui les gens les
plus crédibles pour la population sont
ceux qui parlent le plus pas ceux qui
disent la vérité le mea culpa permanent
sur notre passé dans lesquels des
soi-disant experts se répandent et
ressenti comme une faiblesse sur ce
continent des grandes entreprises
françaises sont l'objet de violentes
attaques de la part de représentants
d'ONG soutenu par leur concurrents
nous avons peut-être perdu une bataille
dans la guerre informationnelle l'an
dernier au Sahel mais nous n'avons pas
perdu la guerre
vous avez eu raison monsieur le ministre
les militaires de l'opération barkhane
ont été irréprochables ils sont notre
fierté
alors
anti-français les Africains
alors expliquez-moi pourquoi les
chiffres de demandes d'inscription pour
étudier en France battent des records en
Afrique l'Algérie en est à 53000 elle
dépasse pour la première fois le nombre
de Marocains d'environ qui est d'environ
30 000 au Togo après une hausse de 73%
sur la période 2016 2021 68 % en 2022
près de 40% d'augmentation des gens
enregistrés cette année un ministre
togolais m'a confié que les Togolais de
France renvoyaient plus d'argent Togo
que l'aide au développement que nous
leurs apportons pourquoi donc se
détournerait-il de nous
dans beaucoup de pays il m'a été dit je
ressens une envie de France un
Camerounais m'a dit ce week-end lorsque
nous avons le partage de la langue la
proximité est plus forte dans notre
inconscient la France et la plus proche
les liens sont forts nos compatriotes
installés en Afrique m'ont tous assuré
qu'ils ne se sent pas menacés en tant
que Français par contre il est vrai que
nous sommes confrontés à une guerre
hybride menée contre l'influence de la
France et ses intérêts économiques avec
quelques euros on paye un journalier
aussi bien pour travailler que pour
manifester avec un drapeau russe devant
l'ambassade de France le sentiment
antipolytique française tout comme le
sentiment anti intérêt français n'est
pas seulement alimenté par les
puissances étrangères et ses proxy dans
plusieurs pays des personnes surf sur du
néo-nationalisme font de la France le
book émissaire de leur difficulté pour
s'imposer politiquement
ma collègue Carlotti a parlé des apôtres
du panafricanisme allez voir qui sont
derrière
ces mouvements populistes gagnent en
visibilité lorsqu'il s'impose il se
jette dans les bras de la Russie de la
Chine de l'Iran et consort on le voit au
Burkina Faso et au Mali il trouve un
écho auprès des acteurs économiques
locaux qui en profitent pour faire du
dégagisme de nos entreprises et
participer ainsi à la prédation de leurs
activités récemment la filiale des
brasseries Castel a été attaquée à coups
de cocktail Molotov en Afrique on
suspecte Wagner de nouvelles menaces
planes sur cette industrielle français
emblématique en Afrique qui a fait de la
responsabilité sociale de l'entreprise
une marque de fabrique qui fait honneur
à notre pays monsieur le ministre avec
l'annonce de retrait de troupes
françaises sur le continent comment
allez-vous défendre nos intérêts
économiques et nos entreprises quand ils
sont directement attaqués comment
justifier vous ce retrait quand on
observe une militarisation accrue de la
Chine pour consolider ces liens
diplomatiques et commerciaux avec le
continent
le retrait de barkhane a fait les
affaires des groupes terroristes au
Sahel et beaucoup s'en rendent compte
dans les pays avoisinants en voyant la
menace progressée
93% des ressources algériennes
proviennent du Sud algérien pour la
première fois depuis 17 ans le chef
d'état-major algérien s'est rendu en
France comment analyse-t-il la situation
sécuritaire au Sahel et envisage-t-il
une coopération militaire le terrorisme
islamiste en Afrique et le visage du
crime international organisé structuré à
l'image des gangs criminelles que j'ai
observé en Amérique latine il se drap
dans un militantisme religieux pour
légitimer les recrutements pour lutter
contre les gangs au Brésil des milices
ont été créés pour protéger des
quartiers les habitants doivent alors se
plier aux règles de la milice et
échangent leur liberté pour obtenir de
la sécurité en Afrique certains pays
font appel à la milice Wagner qui se
paye sur les ressources du pays à
l'image du milice mafieuse contrairement
à ce que certains prétendent la France
n'abandonne pas l'Afrique il y a six
mois j'ai visité la kanumie
internationale de lutte contre le
terrorisme près d'Abidjan
ce centre d'excellence est destiné à
appuyer les pays d'Afrique dans la lutte
contre le terrorisme le modèle de
gouvernance de l'Académie
franco-ivoirienne est un exemple pour la
nouvelle posture de la France en Afrique
je veux saluer la Réunion le 11 mai du
premier conseil d'administration
internationale avec les Australiens
Canadiens Pays-Bas américain ce modèle
interministériel porté par l'Académie
est un exemple nécessaire en Afrique il
évite que l'antitorisme soit porté
uniquement par l'armée avec les risques
de dérapage sur les populations civiles
notre modèle est innovant et mérite
d'être mieux connu combien de pays
africains se sont déclarés intéressés
par cette initiative
madame la ministre l'attribution la
gestion de l'attribution des visas pour
la France est une cause de frustration
observée dans de nombreux pays africains
cela conduit à des décisions
défavorables à la France par exemple
certaines entreprises ont préféré se
fournir en matériel venant d'un autre
pays que la France de peur de se faire
refuser des visas pour une entrée sur le
territoire français et risquée de ne pas
pouvoir former leur personnel de manière
satisfaisante quelles décisions sont
prises pour améliorer notre politique
d'attribution de visa perçue parfois
comme vexatoire en matière d'aide à
l'Afrique il apparaît fondamental des
télépé de ce continent à s'organiser
dans le domaine de la santé pour faire
face à la pénurie de sang et est acheté
auprès de donneurs contaminé hépatique
il est inutilisable à 60% concernant les
médicaments afin de lutter contre les
produits contrefaits et aider les
industriels à servir le continent
pourriez-vous porter l'idée de la
création d'une agence africaine du
médicament
la France porte les valeurs des mots
pratiques j'ai personnellement été
attristé du renversement du président
Roch Kaboré un an après sa réélection
sans intervenir pour protéger cette
démocratie le seul aliment est un état
de la Corne de l'Afrique qui a déclaré
son indépendance en 91 à l'issue de la
guerre civile avec la Somalie pays
actuellement en proie des conflits
depuis plus de 30 ans et qui a des liens
revendiqués avec la Russie comme en
atteste la visite récente du mystole
Malien des Affaires étrangères à Moscou
depuis son indépendance le Somaliland a
su garantir une stabilité politique et
des élections de présidents au suffrage
universel et d'eau de chambres 5
présidents se sont succédé à la tête du
pays depuis son indépendance allons-nous
évoluer sur la question d'une prise en
compte officielle du Somaliland pour
favoriser son développement ou
allons-nous continuer à nous limiter aux
relations avec Mogadiscio la France
comme nos partenaires africains ont
besoin d'une ligne claire fondée sur le
respect mutuel
c'est son de chercher à nous faire aimer
concentrons-nous sur nos intérêts en
faisant valoir nos atouts pour nous
faire désirer un membre du Parlement
togolais l'honorable à lui puis la
résumé ainsi hier devant moi Lomé plutôt
que plus de France optez pour mieux de
France je vous remercie
merci la parole était notre collègue
Nicole Duranton pour le groupe du
Rassemblement